the average EU consumer buys a new  mobile phone every two years but what's  profitable for the market is costing the  environment the majority of old phones  end up in the trash the European  Parliament wants its eco design working  plan to put an end to this wasteful  practice the Parliament is pushing for  green solutions in the methods and  materials used to make everything from  phones to fridges and buildings the aim  of making products last longer and work  better is not only good for the planet  [Music]  one solution to extend the lifespan of  products which is also popular among EU  citizens is to simply repair them as  part of the plan Parliament is drumming  up political support for manufacturers  of modular products that allow parts to  be easily and affordably dismantled and  replaced  [Music]